hello
[Music]
okay there we go hello
are we live
yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
yo yo yo yo yo
what up people
welcome
lightning you were indeed first
congratulations man
good stuff
testing one two one two testing
why is he not stopping on his head
that's kind of weird hi everybody
are the audio levels good
it's a good check i actually checked
before stream so i think we're okay
love your content thank you man i'm glad
you watch it i'm glad you like it
anything specific probably not well
maybe today actually i have some things
that i want to talk about
um
let me turn that on actually
audio is great yes i'd love that
excellent
today's going to be a very short stream
like today might be a shorter stream
than a smoke town video
which isn't hard to do because those
videos are long and they are very good
[Music]
i don't even know if you guys watch
smoke town more than likely you do
more than likely
elden ring lore has been running dry the
past few weeks
tell me about it it really has
it really has i have a specific topic
that i might want to talk about today um
not sure
if i want to though
it had it doesn't have to do with lore
it has to do with the game
smoke town's latest video is great yes
it is
yes it is all his videos are so good
he is the
he's the man
what do we know about turtle pope
he makes funny sounds when he dies
that's what we know
where's my sitting animation
it's right here
there we go
love the content and the streams keep up
the amazing work hey thank you bench
warmer thanks for the 10 super chat man
i appreciate that thank you
thank you
yes i killed the turtle pope because
nobody else will
i'm evil as you can see
can we look at michela's ring with face
cam please it looks like a snake we
looked at it the other day in uh during
day one if you want to go back to that
did you continue your demon souls play
through i talked about this for uh
here hold on i
i said this a few days ago but um
i'm not i'm not huge on demon souls i'm
not like a giant
uh not a big fan honestly
like it's good what is this
what is this
i've never looked below this before
is that sarosh
like a lion
hey i just wanted to see what would
happen if we killed muriel and it's sad
yeah it just looks like a lion
it's gotta be sriracha
he's also right here
but thank thank you again [ __ ] warmer
that's really kind of you thank you
and i'm glad you like the content i will
keep it up
as much as i can
is that godric's emblem
is it a lion
is it really
doesn't melania have a matching ring
let's go find out
does she
let's go see
do you know why exactly mo kidnap miklo
is it even in him in the cocoon i still
don't think it's him in the cocoon
uh but
uh everyone yelled at me about that i
made a video on it and no one liked it
actually a lot of people did like it i
don't know why i said that
on this hand i'm assuming
oh
are her hands put back together do you
see this are they just like really
or is this unalloyed gold
like kind of strap
kind of runs down her arm
what is this right here look at that
is attractive
you guys think moog's attractive
thank you for the five dollars jonah
super chat thank you
that's very kind of you i don't know if
moog's attractive but if you think so
then you must be
thank you man
thank you very much
yeah i don't see a ring here at all
i'm gonna cap on a stack
she has very nice nails
for
the world that we live in here
other hand
dog
bruh okay
the whole point of her character just
having an arm
[ __ ] your chair
examine the branches of the haley tree
up top they have corpse wax wax and
scarlet rot coming off of it
[Music]
i just do whatever you guys say
where like up here
not a lot of detail up here
not gonna cap with chuck
let me make let me get my bearings
really quick
oh where you first spawn in
i
the uh
right up her
don't give us that power i'll do
whatever you guys tell me to do
within reason
[Music]
anyone know there was an item here
oh
nice
all right so what uh like this branch up
here
this is what you're talking about
yeah within within reason we always got
to do within reason right
hi pearlam how are you
i often not often find a creator that's
as engaged with their community as you
are
i love talking with my community i love
it
you guys are pretty cool
i enjoy your presence
you're also very friendly
which i like as well whoa
whoa
i got inverted
[Music]
i'm inverted
i don't know what i'm looking for here i
mean this just look looks like branches
to me
i'm gonna cap with you dawg
[Music]
let me go higher
we
bubble people are all the norix michael
has been [ __ ] with
does mikala really even [ __ ] with
anybody have you guys heard okay maybe
we should talk about this have you guys
heard the theory that we're mickelah has
anyone else heard that before
[Music]
like the character we play as is mikala
i've been hearing that a lot recently
do you say more i don't i don't know i
don't think it's true
that seems wild man
i've just heard people say it i don't
really see the
like evidence for that
yeah based on what it like exactly
i've just been hearing it a lot
i think someone said it and they haven't
made like a you know like a logical
evidence-backed like post or video about
it or anything
but
i don't know
mickeleh will kill his own sister
well
okay so
i think the biggest evidence that i
heard about us being mikola
was
why does everything just kind of like
why does everybody in the world just
kind of accept us right
um i mean what's what's the most obvious
one
because
i'm sure most of you know like the basic
lore of mycola but like he was well
loved by like everybody and he had this
like
ability
to
like make people like him or accept him
or whatever right
so i believe this is like the biggest
evidence that this person said i it
could be like multiple people i have no
idea
um
they said like why does like ronnie
he's just like yeah sure join our thing
why not
you know like isn't that kind of weird
i feel like there are a lot of like
weird moments like that throughout the
game
yeah alabama siblings this this hey this
game is written by george r martin i
don't know how much of it but i don't
know if you guys watch game of thrones
or anything but i don't think
incest is not out of play here okay
definitely incest is uh could be very
normal
up in here dude
goth evening
normalized in this world
but uh someone said in the chat earlier
which may be kind of what i want to talk
about more today is the um
i don't know it feels like the lore has
sort of run dry
does anyone else feel that way
the lore in the game is kind of run dry
we're all just like making
random ass theories and that's pretty
much it there's not much more like
to to do i suppose
until we get dlc
it's because they didn't write any lore
dude i am telling you i don't think they
finished the lore and they did it on
purpose
is that too far of a stretch to say here
i don't think they finished writing
anything because they didn't need to
because they knew the community would
just like
come up with random crap
yeah they're just
are we basically like every video that i
make and smoketown makes and like every
you know lore creator out there
are we just writing the dlc for them
they're like oh that's a cool idea let's
let's make that into a dlc that's a
great idea
not like
you know
not saying we're capable of like writing
a compelling story like that but it's so
weird
has a lot of loose ends and we know they
already cut some content
i have a video coming out in the 18th
um that kind of dives into that a little
bit i have to schedule it for the 18th
because the sponsor on the video wants
me to wait until then
um so wait until this coming friday to
see that like it's not a lot but it's a
little bit
that dives into like some kind of
obvious cut content
not obvious but
literally texture is missing
yeah
we're actually getting a lot of sponsors
lately guys it's kind of cool
i'm not telling you the sponsor you four
heads
can't say that
just wait till friday
and then the 23rd
a lot of sponsors i have to make videos
and then wait because there's like
specific times that they want them out
you guys like raid shadow legends i'm
just kidding
it's not raid shot of legends
does mikala have two fingers
i think he might have ten
there's five right there
oh you put the hand up in her hair
maybe only five
what were we talking
about what is this
oh some unfortunate soul
hi metal
oh also before we continue i am not
gonna be home
for five days i am leaving for la
tomorrow morning
bright and early
and then i'll be gone until friday night
i won't get home till like midnight on
friday so basically saturday
we're talking about incest of course we
are
of course we are
there's a discord we do have a discord
you guys should join it's in the
description
pretty cool happening place
can't believe jake's gonna be awake at
midnight
i probably won't be i'll fall asleep on
the plane and then
this won't wake up
i don't think nicola is the greater will
because it directs you away from the
burning her tree
interesting
what's your favorite from software game
i
i don't think it's this one
i don't think so i like eldon ring
because it's a fantastic
open world game
and i really wasn't even a fan of open
world games before elden ring
but i don't i don't think it's this one
this game has a lot of cool stuff going
on like i absolutely like love how
refined it is based on every other
game out there
i i think i do want to talk talk about i
think i do want to talk about this topic
today with you guys and i'm curious what
you guys think
do you all think
that the biggest issue with eldon ring
is that the game is too big
[Music]
and also to answer your question i would
say my favorite from software game
is dark souls 3. i have 1500 hours in
dark souls 3.
hell no yes kind of sorta i want it
bigger
yeah it's sort of like a kinda right
because that was the main appeal in cell
to the game it was this is big dark
souls it's it's really if you want to
describe elden ring
in a very
basic way it's big dark souls and that's
totally fine
but
the game is so large
that at least for me
and press one in chat if you agree with
me
the game is so big and there's so many
kind of
basic
tedious things that i have to do to make
my character somewhat strong
by gathering smithing stones or going
way out
somewhere to get an item or a weapon or
whatever
it's too much of a hassle to do that so
i just don't want to do that
i just don't want to
does that make sense
at least starting a new character like
new game plus runs are fun for a while
and then you get to new i think it's new
game plus seven i might be wrong on that
i think it's new game plus seven where
all the difficulty just kind of plateaus
it's gonna be as hard as it gets um your
character is obviously gonna be
extremely strong and just keep playing
through the game with like the character
that you build or whatever but then
after that there's like really no point
to it
because
the main like
let me see what you guys are saying
there's almost no direction
i don't think there needs to be
direction
i think that's fine to not have
direction
i'm gonna sit on the throne right in
front of his face
never mind
the like
hmm let me gather my thoughts here
yeah screw direction i don't play elden
ring to have direction
this is because i think elden ring is
the best
is literally the best open world game
that there ever has been
ever
i don't think you can make an open world
game better than they made this one
in my opinion i know there's tons of
balancing issues
there's
uh you know reused bosses all over the
place
but i love
the fact that they don't give me a quest
marker on the map and tell me where to
go
i love that
that's so awesome
the big issue with that though and i
think the big issue with eldon ring in
general
is that you only get that experience
one time
right
that
sense of no direction
and that sense of
discovery you're you're going around an
open world and you're seeing everything
for the first time and it is literally
the best gaming experience that anybody
can have i in my opinion
that it does not get better than that
is the first playthrough of this game
maybe even the second playthrough just
because in a second playthrough
at least for me there was plenty of
stuff that i missed
i completely missed melania my first
playthrough i had to get her a new game
plus one
no idea where she was
never saw her
but i saw her in the trailer and i'm
like where where is this red-haired
chick like where did she go dude never
saw the flame of frenzy i never went
that deep in the sewers didn't know how
to get there got lost in the sewers gave
up went away you know what i'm saying
so you only get that experience that
open world sense of discovery experience
one time
maybe two
and and really not really so
when you're
when you're
playing the game for the second or third
time like we were
just talking about
where
some things feel tedious that's just
because
you know where those tedious things are
because our first and second playthrough
we didn't know what was tedious or not
i can tell you all i've i've 100 of the
game we did it all on stream we did
every single thing this game had to
offer
every single thing we 100 of the game
live on here right
and i can tell you there are plenty of
dungeons that i will never go back to
because it is just not worth it
right
it's just not worth it
i don't want i don't want to
it's boring i didn't like that dungeon
i don't like the item you get at the end
of the dungeon i don't like
the boss at the end of not just that
dungeon but maybe just an area in
general
there are areas that i will quite
literally just never go back to
um
i don't know if you guys are like me
this forest right here
never been back
i went here
once
and i don't know why i just avoid that
area completely
as i'm going there now
with these scary dudes the
yeah these guys
yeah the worm faces
i i just you know
there's not a lot in here besides the
one uh castle that becomes invisible and
you have to unlock it and then the worm
face boss and that's kind of really it
you know
yeah this right here i think it
disappears if i get too close
yep there we go it's gone
um but but the first time i played this
game
the first my first playthrough when i
saw that
i was like whoa
that's so cool right but just as i just
showed you
i'm coming up here and i'm like oh i
already know it's doing it disappear i
have to do this tedious puzzle
that i already know the locations of to
open up the castle
you know what i'm saying
okay so you guys are saying well the
worm face drops something good you're
right
but how much work
how much goes into even getting into
this area after your first playthrough
you have to find
either
the dectus medallions one and two which
one is in the lower part
of
i where where is it like the missed wood
it's in that castle where kenneth hide
is and then the other one is in caled in
the fort
you get both of those then you can take
the dectus lift and then you can become
you can get to all this plateau and then
you can technically get here right
they could be infected beastman that's a
good point
i don't really see it but there's a
potential there because there are worm
faces in fair missoula
or you can go through the mines which
how long does it take for you to ride
there like let's say you get torrent in
your next playthrough you have to see
melania at wherever you get her the gate
front or whatever
uh like right here right and then you
have to ride you can totally skip the
castle you can go this way you can go
the side you have to go all the way
through the lake and and mind you this
is just a straight shot you are just
going to the mines to just get to altus
plateau to get whatever item you like in
this area that's going to take you so
much time and then you're going to get
here way before you want to you're not
going to have an like you're not if you
get in any fight you're gonna die
um
so then you have to go get like smithing
stones
you have to you know
go get some other weapons that you have
to level
another
major issue at least for me
all of this is at least for me i'm sure
lots of people don't have problems with
this and others have other problems
but
i find it so annoying to collect regular
smithing stones
so that i can upgrade one of my weapons
i don't are you guys like that as well
i would rather collect sombers
for weapons
because they're just so much more
uh they're much easier to get
you know
so much easier to get
we have to get the altus plateau to
advance the game anyway
right exactly so you have to go through
all of these tedious things that i'm
saying to even get
here yeah there's like almost too many
somber weapons in too few normal
smithings
this guy gonna run into me
dog
oh
i've never really looked at these guys
up close
right i know where all of those good
minds are as well so i just beeline it
right to those but the entire point of
why i'm talking about that
is because
you're just beelining at that point
you're like i know where those good
somber smithing stones are i know where
those good smithing stones like mass
quantities of them i know where those
dungeons are and you beeline it right to
those areas just to get the upgrades
and then
maybe i'm wrong on this also
but
i feel like normal enemies don't drop
enough runes
you pretty much have to kill main bosses
to get enough runes
to be able to upgrade those weapons and
your character to be able to even be
able to use those weapons that you want
right are they crying
sorry i've never really looked at these
before
is that okay so this looks like an ear
right here right
like on the side of the head right here
a little ear action
and then are these eyes
no they're just like dots
you get some light
anyway
stat requirements are too high
yeah i'm not sure but right the the main
point of me talking about all of this
stuff
is that it makes me not want to play the
game again
and we've seen that it isn't it like 90
95 percent of the player base
just stopped playing
because they beat the game once
oh did zoli make a video on them okay i
need to watch that
i don't think i've seen her video on
that yet
guy i kind of took it as laughing as
well
yeah that's laughing
kinda are they coughing
tough to tell it's some [ __ ] noise
something
that is always the case with literally
every single player game ever why do i
have 1500 hours in dark souls 3 then
does metal babe five this is just
somebody i know why does metal babe have
thousands of hours in dark souls one
whoa
lots of people have that many hours
i i don't think we can just say that you
know that's usually the case with uh
single-player games because that's way
too obvious
like duh that happens with every game
ever like even multiplayer games die off
after the first like two weeks it's out
and then has their core
because it's a smaller shorter game
that's
that's my whole point is like eldon ring
is too big
i've never had that feeling in like dark
souls 3 or dark souls 1
where
i say to myself i don't want to
i don't want to play it because it's
just too much
when this game is totally like marketed
not marketed but there's obviously a lot
of replayability in this game you have
so many different like classes
weapons
all kinds of different things to do in
this game
but so many people were just like no
i'm gonna do my one
uh and then i'm done
and even i somebody who makes content
for this game as a job
have that
have that same feeling where it's like i
don't wanna play through the game again
so i have to do all kinds of like
creative things to keep me like
wanting to play the game
you know
you make a character beeline to all the
good stuff and then clone the character
as a starting point
and then clone the character as a
starting point
is that a solution
oh
replayability over a long time though
tough to say
there's two little main bosses in the
game
yeah there's a lot of like small bosses
but how many of those like stuck out to
you right
radon
melania
ranala
moog
i mean we fight morgot three times
basically
different move set for morgot
fire giant
i know i'm missing some
those are like the big godric
you know
but then there's like 160 something
total bosses
i know i'm missing some but
that's the point
yeah godfrey twice
the wolf twice
three times
with the yeah the red the red wolf right
card of course sorry
right card
reichard
is one of my favorite bosses in the game
i know it's a i know it's a gimmick boss
but it is one of my favorites
it's the the gimmick of it is so well
done that i i love that boss
bowling star beast yeah i mean that is
unique we do fight them a lot though or
you can
yeah placa do sacks for the sacks
through
yeah the godskins we fight a lot
true
yeah it's a reichardt is a gimmick fight
done perfectly
[ __ ] so there are a lot
i mean are there
like that i would say that's probably as
many memorable bosses as there are in
dark souls 3
dark souls you know
i hate the elden beast fight i [ __ ]
hate it it's so bad
there might be a lore reason why we
can't use torrent for that fight
but we r it felt like the elden beast
boss was designed for us to use torrent
in it and we don't and it's weird
why are these guys here
yeah ratagon is an amazing fight but i
cannot stand the elden beast
me look into those eyes
rate the attractiveness scale one to ten
it's a it's a 12.
a face only a mother could love
they do have horns going on here
just thinking almond wise here
yeah and 11 yeah
look at these horns
why do the misbegotten like mikala
because we've had this theory that
mikola could potentially be
trying to cure the almonds maybe
along with the scarlet rot
they kind of look like wings
kinda but then there's this bad boy
right here he's got a bunch of horns
right here
are these um
flame of frenzy eyes it's kinda got that
orange reddish yellow to it
i like the elden beast fight it was
bordering between two abstract and
perfect for the strange journey of chaos
i don't know i don't like it when a boss
runs away from me constantly
that's just me
hugism is begotten
what are the misbegotten they're just
like a race in this world aren't they
some of them
look at the misbegotten wings and then
mickelas and the opening of the game
wait i hit this guy so he doesn't move
is it worth it to serve ronnie if you
like ronnie then yeah sure
does mikala have wings excuse me
what
demi-human omens there's a potential for
that we're never gonna know but
potential for that
uh
what am i looking up
nicola
this one
the heck is this
you talking about these stumpy things
right here
right here
do we even know this is mikala
what's really inside nicholas egg
i mean
these kind of look like wings
kinda
uh
i'm looking
mikala
and moog
was this inverted i kind of like that
wait
it's not
okay this looks a lot better though
right here oh there's another one right
here
kinda
do make a list statues have wings
um we don't know what timeline this is
in and we don't know what statues the
timelines are in so it's kind of hard to
like tell
i mean i must like if we're talking very
basic and we're saying like this is
mikala and the dude in the cocoon is
mykola
i
like thinking very
basically and what a cocoon is like
meant to do
is like change you right you change like
at least in real life like
a caterpillar goes into a cocoon and it
turns into a butterfly right
there are butterflies in the game
like
does that have to do with mikala
hold on let me get somewhere where it's
not raining
oh
i gotta kill this guy
he doesn't like me
where should we go let's go up here
he has blood hair which godwin also had
you mean blonde
there's like a ton of different
butterflies
it's a moth not a butterfly okay so it
doesn't have to be a butterfly you're it
a cocoon that is changing mikola right
like let's say mikla's in the cocoon
and
he's morphing into something else
probably i would assume
like the hailik tree he created to help
cure
uh the scarlet rod help his sister right
whereas the
the cocoon was maybe to help morph him
from his eternal youth
that's a i think that's
very very basic
but it's possible right
would it be a tool
there's like smoldering
something
it's probably a craftable item yeah yeah
okay smoldering butterfly
an eternally burning butterfly found
near wildfires and elsewhere
serves as kindling for a number of items
okay
i mean what what are these fireflies
real quick
light of butterflies believed to have an
alert magic golden light is considered
okay so nothing a butterfly with
withered scarlet rot wings found in the
swamp of aeonia according to a myth
these butterflies were once the wings of
the goddess abroad herself
it's like eh
his mom america's blonde hair oh we can
we can get to that too uh
i saw a theory out there somewhere that
the woman we see when we enter the er
tree or the radagon fight is not queen
america
and i'm like dude everything i know
about this game is just wrong like
is that you know like maybe that
person's just straight up wrong and
i don't have to think that way but i
have heard that and i'm like
give me evidence man you can't just say
that
you know
because if that's true then like wow
okay
but it has to be because it turns
into
ratagon which america's ratagon
radagon is america
but then you could say like
it fell out of frame and then
it's not what we see it as
you can see your body crumbling
in the uh statue form afterwards like
when we mend the elden ring so it's not
the it's not even ratagon it's like what
the frick bro
are you talking about
in mikala's
mouth
in the intro there is an arm dangling
from his mouth
the same is in the cocoon
also everything in the intro is in the
past in my opinion
but how far in the past
right
like
getting a timeline down
is so
hard
i mean do i have paint on here
let's get let's get
some high quality production on the
stream going right here right guys
look at this guy go
with paint
let's create a timeline
high quality
so
what happened first
let's put it in the middle
uh just right there
in the center
the
shattering
or is that
not like
a good place to put it i don't know
the shattering
boom
there it is right in the middle
objection
this is not big enough i am so sorry
i don't know how to use this so this is
making it i also don't want to like use
my handwriting as well
i want it delete
okay i'm starting a new one
don't save
i don't know how to use this bro
oh
it's way too big
stop it
okay
okay
okay shat stands for shattering
so the crucible was the beginning where
all life was melded together where are
you getting that from
like did the dragons come before them or
the crucible
when did all of these [ __ ] aliens
come down
i'm gonna put the crucible
like here
great tree right
crucible
this is really hard to type like this
do you see how hard this is like i can't
even begin to think
of
everything that we could possibly put on
here
i'm pretty sure it went gre dragons to
crucible tree from space
the great tree isn't a thing
is the great tree not a thing
how come i've heard that so many places
but it's not a thing now
of course it is why did someone say it's
not real
the way i have it in my brain right now
is that the crucible is the great tree
it's the [ __ ] tree before it was uh
taken over right
by the greater will by the golden order
at this point in like all of my time
playing this game i see this golden tree
as like it's basically fake it's not
even [ __ ] real
maybe
that's the whole thing the whole like
the thing with the lore in this game is
everything's like well maybe
like we can't even make a timeline
because it's like impossible to tell
it's hard to read
[ __ ] it
i'm
done
i can't even see my thing this doesn't
even help us anyway
the base of the tree is real
yeah as we get closer to it
and then it like it's been there for
who knows how long
but haven't you guys like stood at a
distance and noticed that the tree is
transparent
hold on i don't know exactly where to go
for this
i think i usually see it like here
i'll go way down here and that could
just be like the game is
not loading in all the way or whatever
maybe
yeah
maybe right guys
i see you angel okay
it is exhausting
that's a great way to put the lore in
this game
it is exhausting okay i'm too far away
actually let me go like
here
melano's glow my queen maybe
it's like dude
like i'm pretty set on melano being the
glow mid queen
but maybe not
maybe
all right well i know i've definitely
played the game
and it's been
it's been [ __ ] transparent
press one in chat if you've seen the
tree be transparent before
at least while you're riding around or
whatever and then you look at the tree
and it's suddenly like wait how come i
can see through the tree
and again that could just be
the game's not loading
or whatever
i don't know
with a telescope
i'm trying to get an angle oh wait i
forget i have an amazing free cam mod
translucent not transparent
translucent sorry
like i could drop 2500 words on why
america not melana is the glomide queen
and it would make sense but probably
still be wrong exactly
[Music]
what happens if i just fly up here
what's going on in here
whole lot of nothing
man this game looks good from a distance
huh i mean [ __ ]
okay
it's just a legendary skin
excellent
welcome to the void i've never had
like
[Music]
i've never had this much of a of an
issue
trying to understand
a souls game
and it's lore right
like i totally understand bloodborne and
i totally understand dark
souls sekiro is so straightforward but
even the way they tell this game
it's so
is straightforward
it is
but
it's just not
it's it there's so much happening which
goes into more of what we were talking
about earlier that this game is too big
it's so hard to put everything together
and like you just said handyman i think
we just have to be patient
and wait
or dlc
and be like
okay
answer some questions for us please
do you guys think
yes or no
that dlc for elden ring will come out in
2022 this year
okay a lot of you guys are saying no
totally agree
i don't know how they could
come out
with dlc this year
i don't know how they could
how how long do you think a dlc in
comparison to elden ring the game itself
that probably took us hundreds of hours
each to beat
maybe not that much like at least 50
hours to beat the game i would say right
at least 50 probably closer to 100 in
between there somewhere to beat the game
how long do you think a dlc has to be to
even warrant it
you know
mykolo is mickela thank you yes
[Music]
15 hours minimum
for a dlc
yeah
depends on how good you are as well like
how fast you can beat a boss to
the kind of that kind of factors in a
bit for each player right
dlc might also be huge
i mean are they just going to make an
entirely new area
or are they going to put it somewhere
out here because at least to me
i see
the dlc
like changing the landscape kind of like
how we did when we beat radon
right
like okay so here's here's what i see
happening for dlc
okay
we're gonna go to nicola
this this is what i think they're gonna
do for dlc
this just seems so uh
dark soulsy to me
is we are going to walk up to that hand
right there and we're going to touch it
and we're going to go into myklas dream
world
that must be one of the dlc's
has to be
maybe something else with ranala as well
because she's kind of just sitting there
doing her thing
like we're gonna go right there and
we're gonna like go in a pool of blood
and that's where we're gonna go we're
gonna go in wherever moog comes out of
here right
wouldn't that be cliche at this point
though
i don't know
i don't care if they put a text screen
up in front of us saying do you want to
start dlc and then it displaces us
somewhere else i would love that
i'll take anything at this point man
i'll take anything give me anything
but it's not gonna happen this year
yeah we can check moog for a snake ring
somewhere
alone a while i don't think he does he
just has a horned finger that flips you
off
oh welcome
honor to guests yeah we could go back in
time that's also true i would love that
oh
i didn't sting
dynasty
i love how he just wanders around
i also want to talk to radon before he
goes nuts
i really do too
you guys are hoping for a time travel
dlc
okay so
if there is a time travel dlc how do you
think it'll happen like what do you
think will do
to like enter it because if you guys
have ever played
other souls games in the past they have
a very creative way of getting you into
the dlc
in all of the games it's not like it's
just gonna happen you have to like go
find it
which is pretty cool
mug's flipping you
off uh
dude half his hand goes through his
weapon
i don't see a ring
no ring
whoa
wait
his eyes are reflective it's kind of
sick
the arenas are a big no-brainer
to go back in time
yeah no rings howie
i mean we already went back in time with
sax
so like you think we're just gonna like
lay down and like
enter here again
now
also another thing i've never really
checked around this area
because we're back in time right but is
anything else around here
what's underneath whoa
what is that
what's this right here
that's where we that's where we lay down
right
i think that's where we lay down
to enter the fight right
okay we got a lot of oh
what
huh
why do they leave these in here
who's this guy
just a stoney boy
it's for the cut scene
okay we still got dragons flying around
well below so we can't even see it
that's kind of strange
okay
[Music]
yep guys it's mickeleh he's right here
it's mickela he's a dragon now
there he is
fully rendered fire excellent
which fog gate is this
does every boss fight have to have a fog
gate technically
malacats oh you're probably right
so we are just very far above pharah
missoula for this fight got it okay
i think that's what i'm getting here
yeah it's the dlc foggit
yup
oh
all those bodies look kind of cool from
down here
let's take a look at our our boy here
that head is gone dog
damn
what'd you do i broke it
i'd like to see more humans become
dragons
and godric tried it
who cut those off
it's pretty much confirmed that it was
godfrey right
maybe
you know what don't even answer that
everyone say maybe because that's the
answer
i feel like everything everyone asks is
like well it could be this maybe
maybe
could be
[Music]
america could be the glomide queen
i think that's technically right
because
okay
melon is the glow my queen
right
maybe
like i i gotta it's gotta be
it has to be melana
this is so much evidence
to melana the thing with that is
is that i believe that melano
is
america
i think she's a fragment of america
that she created for all kinds of
reasons
so when you say america is the glomide
queen
well
technically but not really you know what
i'm saying
maybe
maybe it's hard to say
hard to say
where can we talk to her
where can i
see her
kinda
let's go here
i can explain
right churches that would have been the
easiest way thank you i'm just
i forget things my my mind is in 50
different places at once honestly all
the time
hello
spoken echoes linger here
words of queen america
who vanished long ago how long ago
give me
the year in time and date that she
disappeared
now
[Music]
right now
watch we find a uh
a snake ring on her
nope
1983.
uh there's a point where speculation
turns from fun into frustration i think
eldon ring left up too much to
speculation i think more answers would
have been better
i agree but
did did we really expect from software
to tell us a story that made sense
from the get-go
hell no
and i will say
that
dark souls and bloodborne were confusing
until
eldon ring or not
not
until dark souls and bloodborne were
confusing until dlc came out then
everything made a lot more sense
afterward
so i think we just got to be patient
we're gonna we're gonna investigate her
nostrils
look at that eye
[Music]
let's get
closer neat
enhance
there's a lot of detail in these eyes
everybody's a dog and that's the lore
excellent
does america have a golden eye as well
no no we don't know
we have no [ __ ] idea
[Music]
oh by the way
i haven't told anybody this besides
metal babe when i go to la
let me guys i'm gonna get this anyway
whether you say it's a cool tattoo idea
or not
i'm obviously not getting this on my
face but i was gonna get this
uh like tattoo like scar on my hand
i think it'd be a cool tattoo
to like put it like up and down my index
finger leading into my thumb like a
little bit of a curve i think that's
sick
to do like this
stinky
get it on your taint that would hurt
maybe
no on the top of my hand not on my palms
on the top
[Music]
if i get it i'll take a picture of it
and post it in the community tab
you don't mean what it means in the lore
though i to me it looks like
um the elden beast claw
to me
which hides her gloam eye or the golden
like the golden order the greater will
like hiding
that part of her
but
mainly signifies
could it could be some other things
it could be
like the beast claw
could be the three fingers okay you know
the answer is
maybe
[Music]
the death birds glow my queen
sure
ronnie does not have this i don't
believe no
always thoughts of three fingers
you could be right
maybe
i should just retitle this stream to
maybe
yeah it could be
sure
yeah
okay
thank you nick i'm glad you like him man
ronnie has the same symbol but turned
around
really
i don't think so
you know what maybe of course tell me
get up and let me leave
hey maybe guys all right
imagine having a face tattoo uh
that's pretty hardcore
oh
piss
where can i see her
i have to go here
ready went too far
ravenclaw
hey guys just so you know
just so you're aware
saying something like respond [ __ ]
does not make me
want to answer your what you said it
doesn't make me want to respond and then
spamming the same thing over and over
again also doesn't make me want to do
that
just so you know
so how about you
shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're literally talking about freaking
nothing
go wipe your butt
i bet you didn't get all the [ __ ] that's
in it
it's pretty clear
i don't see nothing there but we don't
yeah
that's one dead ass eye
yeah it's kind of a rough model let's do
this
let's do this
we'll do the blue
oh i have two people to ban
bye bye
i don't like you goodbye
by the way that guy telling me to
respond he is now banned he's now the
second person in three months of
streaming this game that has ever been
banned just so you know
i banned two people
not including bots
but she'll show up after this and then
we'll look at her at her normal model
that's too much what
we do have we have a great community
it's awesome
our community is really cool
okay looking at this better model
i'm not seeing the same mark
anywhere
are you guys
light mode windows
i don't yeah i don't care
i'm not seeing it boys
and girls
not not seeing it there
could have swore she had a mark
i'm not
not seeing it i'm looking even at the
ghost face here
which i always thought like really when
the game first came out i'm like oh uh
melania's connected to ronnie and like
this is melania
i think it's just her spirit coming out
of it you know
i think it's just your spirit coming out
of it a little like tugging outside of
it
i think everybody thought that melana
was like connected to ronnie in some way
but i don't think so
i don't know
ryan is the only character that mentions
melania i think they're definitely
connected in some way but not like uh
that this ghostly form is melania i
don't think that's the case
yeah we see the closed eyes and then
everyone you know
i think it was a fair assumption when
the game first came out but not not
anymore
maybe there you go
that's mikula could be mickela
hmm
hmm
[Music]
are we mikala i've heard that theory
i don't know about that though
i don't know about that
let's see
one
two
three
or
[Music]
five
wait five
six
are you mickela
i love how whenever i like get slightly
toxic to one viewer who was being an
[ __ ]
other people come out of the woodwork to
also do that because they have this like
kink
of me doing the same to them it's kind
of weird
it was like totally fine and then once
that happens it's like
yeah ban me elden daddy
except your theories suck
and that reddit carries you
i haven't been on reddit in months
so i have no idea what you're talking
about
me live
lying through your teeth
excellent
good to know
no i know handyman
that's what i'm saying they like get all
crazy because they just want attention
jake your vids smoketown and vati are
the best lorvids for eldon ring have you
ever
covered elder scrolls before
elder scrolls lore no i haven't
have not
i played them though
i like i played skyrim when it came out
but i didn't
i wasn't even making content
i was in high school
have you checked radon's armor i feel
like
they might have thrown something on
there
i mean i've looked at it pretty close it
just kind of is a like signifier of
sriracha don't you think
do you think you'll cover other games
once elden ring starts to slow down
significantly
i'm not sure i don't know
i for now we're just doing elden ring
because
yeah
there's really no point in doing
anything else
i would like to though i would
absolutely love that
but for now no
let's see what he's wearing
i am not changing my name to elden daddy
i haven't really looked at this too
closely before
because it kind of just breaks it
lord of rings
lord of the rings lord of rings
uh i've seen the movies once
i wasn't too huge on them they're good
though i've seen them all
this kind of reminds me of the rolled
medallion
but it's not quite the same
wait is this the same um
kind of ruin that's on the sword i have
right now
not roon
you know what i mean
not really i mean it's the same kind of
color
yeah kind of like a cyborg eye type of
deal
can we like see your face in here
how do you see anything
sir
what
beautiful
let's go check the
grank that's a good idea
i don't think any of these
any of these could be a movie
i don't think so
well look at that
he does
[Music]
same model
but why would this be here
magma whip candlestick
i mean i'm sure everybody here thought
that malakath and this guy were the same
person when you first saw them right
he's not holding the blade
however his hand is just open
nothing there
hmm
that's right so when he pulls it out
when you attack him
okay sorry
i'm trying to
yeah
trying to think
the beastman threw it away well we don't
know if the beastman threw it away
yeah the blade's over here isn't it
i even get out this way
nope
those drapes are godwin's cloth
oh god now i have the check
there's there's so many avenues of this
being
just malakath
the same clergyman that's in pharah
missoula
these drapes up here i'm pretty sure his
are green and these are blue
they just look similar okay
they're not the same
they say they're different
you say they're different is just okay
gotcha
they're undeniably the same person i
really don't think we can say that
undeniably so
considering people can change
into the same person while also having
different consciousnesses
wait i kind of have to jump from up here
hold on
i mean
i had that theory as well where pharaoh
missoula is like frozen in time
uh a lot of people pointed out that you
can
like pharah missoula is exactly the same
as when you like wherever you're looking
at it from like we can see it from here
there's even um grank in there can come
out here and like howl toward pharah
missoula right
i think i've seen that clip before
i've never seen it in game myself
however
is there like a proper path down here
it's like over here isn't it
these little tree branches
let's try it
oh god
nice
yeah
oh god
okay
the moog pit
is definitely the worst platforming
section
is it not down here
i have to go lower i swear it was like
oh i gotta keep going okay
what's further down
oh
a bat
ow
sorry torrent
do i keep going i don't remember it
being this far down
although i haven't done this in
months
split
okay sorry i was just looking around
oh this is for a mid dagger
well i actually already have it i just
kind of want to see where it is okay i
see i see
like if there's anything that's like
kind of
giving us tells of like why it would be
there
oh god
you know
things like that
okay
do you hear that
do you hear a difference there
is there a waterfall here
what waterfall
even when i go out here it goes away
[Music]
hmm
this is kind of weird
hmm
okay
heavy wind
yeah
just overthinking it
definitely overthinking it
let's take a look at it though
i already had three of them excellent
short sword given to high ranking
clergyman of pharaoh missoula raised his
opponent see of bcl incantations the
design celebrates obese
five fingers
symbolic of the intelligence once
granted upon their kind
skill prized by the crafty
and fleet of foot
oh that's just quick step okay
intelligence once granted upon their
kind
you look at this
wait take one hand off
oh
why locked
there we go
kind of looks like a meteoric stone
one two three four five
does this not look like
the fingers
that are on
melania's scar
look at the statue in melliket's arena i
think the person who granted them smarts
the the statue with the three dogs
five fingers like plastidusak's five
heads
yeah you can draw fingers in a lot of
different ways i think that's too far of
a stretch to say that
for sure
this can't say for sure
made out of gravel stone
oh it's literally right here small clump
of sharp pointed stones
such compound stones
found in the lands once beset by ancient
dragons
said to be the scales of those very
beasts
maybe
why is it small when we get it
you know
that's just how it works out here
[Music]
you know we can't have well that's not
true i mean imagine if we had the exact
size of radon's blades
or his swords
you imagine
we just there'd be no shot that we could
hold it
i mean based on what everyone's saying
in the chat that grank is malakath
i don't like how hairy the fingers are
you don't like hairy fingers
it is a little gross
it's okay though
a beast man
i don't know
[Music]
hmm
okay
just thinking
we're already standing straight up sick
rapture
can you read uh descriptions of
gestures
is that a thing
yes they are erect
excellent
oh
i don't think you can
yeah that'd be weird
ronnie's two fingers is bloody yeah
because she ripped a hole in it
with the finger slayer blade
what is out east of that divine tower
baron missoula
malacath turns to karank after he loses
death and death
wouldn't that
basically
confirm
that pharah missoula is always outside
of uh
our time
wouldn't that just confirm that
oh they really uh
oh this is not very good is it
uh
[Music]
via burning the tarnished innards he
stole
that could make sense
i like that theory
handgun
plus zero what you expect oh i thought i
put on the plus 10 one
maybe i didn't
yeah i've i've recamed outside here
before it's nothing there's just nothing
out here
just absolutely nothing
outside of this round table
if you get all
give malcath all the death root he
recognizes you in the boss fight
at the beginning
i know he changes his dialogue after you
defeat him
is the round table inside or the ur tree
oh at the beginning and the end
okay
gotcha
but he doesn't unless we give him all of
it right
all of the death root
i wonder why that triggers his
memory i guess
banished night armor
in the round table
so these statues right here i've noticed
are on most
of the divine tower bridges
they don't remind me of all bastards but
i could be wrong
they're on all the bridges
i mean my theory on this round table is
that it isn't real and it's a
manifestation or like
it was created to serve as just like
i i would think technically it would be
inside melana
like she created this place for the
tarnish to go
which is based on a real round table
that's in the capital city
inside melody nice
yeah that's great
reminds me of all the creepy statues of
the swamp castle
swamp castle i mean i i see them on
pretty much every bridge
that's that's where i recognize them
from
right here
yeah i could explain how she teleports
there
what's a discord call
pretty sure it's the same
oh shaded
castle i think that's yeah that might be
what you mean
created with the two fingers inside
could be
i believe that melano is a fragment of
america
and the two fingers and the finger
maiden that we talked to
is
queen america's two fingers
does that make sense
let's go to the shaded castle because i
don't think
these are in the shade castle but could
be wrong let's go check it out
let's go here
you're talking about these right
could be made by the same person the
same artist
[Music]
but all of them are different from the
ones on the bridges
i think the glomide queen is related to
the carions taurians as
a godskin
is near somewhere that is related to
them
a noble at volcano manor a noble at
ronnie's tower bridge and one at radon's
tower
haven't i i'm pretty sure i've heard the
theory somewhere that um
well no i think that was
geeted out never mind i'm not even gonna
say it
yeah none of these have like that the
the divine bridge like sword
type statue but it definitely reminds me
of them just none of them are here
this guy's the biggest simp in the game
yeah who are these statues of
excellent
whoop gone
hold on people
there we go
sorry i forgot to ban that guy from
earlier too there we go
all right now we've had to ban three
people and two of them are from tonight
that's not very good chat
that's not very pogers
a mini melania statue in the same
hallway
what lore have we found so far
absolutely nothing everything is a maybe
that's where we're at
it's a bit frustrating just a bit
you mean america
[Music]
there's still time to up that number
let's
let's not let's not do that
it's just not
i love how i'm still dealing with people
from reddit from that situation from
quite literally four months ago it's
just
crazy to me
but that's fine
maybe everything is a maybe i think
that's the only guarantee that we
possibly could have in this game
that everything is a maybe
and it it is frustrating
you think that bloodborne and elden ring
are connected i don't i don't
i don't
what situation i made a video on it four
months ago you can go back and check it
out you will if you look at the
thumbnail you will know which one it is
but ever since this situation i have not
been back on reddit in four months
and every time it's brought up it gives
me crippling anxiety
which is just not fun
crippling
why america final boss look like a
statue
because the very thing that keeps them
in existence is broken
how do you feel about the new patch it's
really good
it they fixed all the balancing issues
that everyone was complaining about
which i think is great
yeah these streams are just meant to
like talk with chat i don't know why
anyone would think like you're not
talking about anything it's like well
yeah no [ __ ] dumbass we're all here to
just talk about everything
it's like it's okay
that we don't talk about anything
specific i like it i like just randomly
talking with chat about stuff
i like talking to my chat that's the
entire point
you got caught on reddit pretending to
be the ronnie simp king
no
yeah no
no
no
do they go to the bathroom
i don't think you know you know never
mind your answer you're asking the right
questions here
do the tarnish go to the bathroom
i don't know
i think uh as we ride around on torrent
we just poop our pants
just pissing our britches
onions rise
gosh there's just so many things to look
into in this game man
so many
a dog
i love you
excellent
keep my wife's name out your [ __ ]
mouth
exactly
no i just had a really bad experience
with reddit i got one of those um
mass hate raids
like four months ago
like thousands of people it was not fun
at all
and then the person who started it was
literally banned from the elden ring
subreddit
so
it was dealt
with but
why is there a giant flying turtle
a giant
flying turtle
uh like i said i made a whole video on
it four months ago addressing it you can
go watch that
if you want
i don't know why there's a tower up here
hmm
yeah giant flying dog
i think so moderate i just haven't
looked into it
when you think the dlc release we talked
about this a little bit earlier but i
don't think it will be this year that's
all i know
i don't know anything that's just my
guess
better way to put it
um
had no idea this guy was here
what
why are you here
no clue this guy was here
fork
what book are you holding
who are you
yeah there's one in the underground it's
the wolf of ratagon there's several of
them
i thought there were only three but this
is four
same girl holding a book smithing stone
oh there was something here as well
smithing stone
seven or three of them
wow talk about a good spot to get some
smithing stones holy [ __ ]
okay
is there one in the snow fields
you're the dragon
i'm just calling everything mikola now
cool
just everything i come across in this
game i'm just like why are these here
why what are you doing here
what is your purpose
why is that there
seems like a random ass spot for that
can i even get anywhere with this
no
oh it's for the
puzzle is that what someone meant that
there's a turtle here
am i
like just not
hold on
it doesn't matter what i use
okay maybe i have to have this off
i need to go to bed soon i have to get
up so early
catch a flight
oh i have to activate it
okay well that's cool to know
i don't really want to do it
which uh
yeah now we're just kind of roaming
around
i have like a billion things on my brain
right now
oh that's a riot
it's you can i grab the sky
oh i'm dead
electo is nuts
okay
people i think i need to get off
i have to do some more things before
i go to bed because i'm
i have an early flight tomorrow to los
angeles
so i have a billion things on my brain
right now and i can't be thinking
all the lore stuff
i will be gone all week monday through
friday to go see metal babe it's very
exciting
um
yeah i will try and
somehow structure structure
these streams because i feel like it
would lead to like
better
i don't know better discussions probably
it's just
it's difficult when you know
i do i think i get overwhelmed like i
definitely did tonight i got overwhelmed
with like
the everything we're trying to talk
about and then uh everyone asking
questions and then i read them and then
i lose my train of thought i'm not very
good at that so
but that's okay
it happens
no problem
it is a bit chaotic and then eventually
we're just like i'm so overwhelmed that
i don't even know what we're talking
about anymore and we just talk about
everything at once which is pretty hard
um
man i would love to play dark souls 3 i
love that game
but
we'll see so i'll try and get a video
out by tomorrow before i leave but
that'll that'll be difficult um
definitely i have a video scheduled for
this friday
we have a sponsor for that video so
that's pretty cool
so look out for that um other than that
though
i'm just going on vacation
this week and i'm and i'm just gonna
focus on having fun
there is a lot to cover with elden ring
that's kind of the problem is i really
like having like a structured main focus
of something to talk about and then like
when i get
sidetracked with like a billion other
things it's just it's overwhelming i'm
sure it is for everyone else too but
that's okay we're gonna be fine i'm to
get off though i'm going to go finish
packing and make sure i'm all ready to
go for tomorrow because it's pretty
early flight so
y'all take it easy appreciate y'all
being here thank you very much
and i'll see y'all i'll probably stream
again
next weekend because i'll be gone like i
said so
have a great week have a great night
and i'll see you all very soon
take care bye bye bye
see you dudes